[Música]
lo que me inspira me apasiona en esta
vida es sentirme libre amo pero amo ser
sinaloense y quienes seamos de sinaloa
siempre nos verán sentirnos orgullosos
de nuestras raíces
presumiendo les que tenemos la mejor
comida que jamás hayan probado y
conocerán a la gente más alegre
divertido y pachanguera
se los prometo terminarán siendo los
mejores amigos definitivamente quien
visita a sinaloa se enamora de todo lo
que ofrece
justamente fue creada en un pueblo de
sinaloa donde viví los mejores años de
mi vida junto a mi familia y mis amigos
donde todo era tan espontáneo tan
divertido tan de pueblo
que yo llegaba a mi casa llena de tierra
de pies a cabeza empapada de agua y con
uno que otro respondo recuerdo una de
las tantas travesuras que hice con mis
amigas fue justamente en las vías del
tren literal un puente y por debajo
pasaba el río nuestro reto era correr y
llegar al punto que te diera miedo y
regresarnos sin que el tren pasara ya
estoy viendo sus caras qué miedo donde
estaban tus papás no las cuidaban pudo
suceder un accidente
pero en adrenalina y unas ganas de
querer llegar más lejos de animar a mis
amigas para que lo hicieran de ayudarla
si se quedaban paralizadas y al final
todas terminaba en risas carcajadas nos
subíamos a nuestras bicicletas y nos
íbamos a la huerta de mangos de una de
mis mejores amigas nos comíamos un
delicioso ceviche de camarón debajo de
esos enormes árboles con hamacas y
columpios
y al final terminamos bañándonos en una
llanta de tractor y si así fue gran
parte de mi niñez y adolescencia aquí
fue mi crianza junto a mis padres donde
mi papá tenía algunos negocios en el
pueblo y me daba algunos encargos
aprendí a negociar con las personas a
sacar las cuentas del día a saber
recibir una mercancía
y yo lo observaba como él se dirigía a
cada uno de sus empleados pero algo que
yo tengo muy grabado que él siempre
decía es mejor tener tu negocio es mucha
dedicación pero el tiempo es tuyo nadie
te da órdenes y puedes disfrutar de la
vida a tu manera y por otro lado mi mamá
quien era maestra me enseñó el orden la
disciplina a siempre estar aprendiendo
definitivamente fue la combinación
perfecta recuerdo que emprendí
muchísimos negocios por supuesto mi papá
era mi prestamista por ejemplo en mi
casa teníamos un árbol de mangos y junto
con mi hermano vendíamos mangos por las
calles después puso un letrero fuera de
mi casa que decía se venden bolis y para
la época de verano vendía salvavidas y
mil cosas para jugar en la playa
y después cuando llegaban mis primos en
diciembre les decía que hiciéramos una
tiendita de dulces afuera de la casa de
mi abuela
y al final enterramos el dinero en una
de sus macetas que -según para el
próximo diciembre que nos viéramos
gastarlo en comprar cohetes o dulces
claro pasaron los años y jamás
encontramos la maceta con nuestro ahorro
millonario
con todo este empuje atrás decidí
estudiar una carrera que tuviera que ver
con negocios siempre teniendo en mente
las palabras de mi padre
al tiempo decidí llevar una vida godín y
sentía que algo faltaba
ya que empezaba un trabajo y terminaba
un año y medio máximo y terminaba
renunciando entonces decía algo hace
falta me sentía frustrada buscaba otra
opción y tampoco era la indicada y así
varios años no me malinterpreten en cada
uno de estos trabajos aprendí muchísimo
conocí a grandes personas que hoy son
grandes amigos creo que la vida y dios
fueron poniéndome en cada uno de estos
lugares por la razón de crecer en mi
manera de ser de aprender a negociar de
tener todo listo para ahorita de saber
dirigirme adecuadamente con clientes y
proveedores de saber resolver un
problema de ponernos la camiseta y
jugárnosla como equipo hasta organizó
una convención anual que fue algo que me
gustó muchísimo y de verdad yo atesoro
cada momento vivido
pero en una de estas empresas me dice mi
director y me pongo seria
carla
aquí no es donde tú quieres estar y así
vayas a la empresa más fregona y te den
el puesto que tú crees el indicado no
estarás conforme porque todo lo que tú
realmente quieres hacer no está ninguna
empresa pero te toca a ti descubrir es
el lugar donde te sientas desarrollada
profesional y personalmente
créanme que esas palabras taladraban mi
cabeza a qué se refiere entonces donde
es mi lugar una frustración que ni yo
entendía
entonces qué hago un viaje con mis
amigas lo organiza una de ellas y
teníamos todo listo sin preocuparnos por
nada pero justo fue esos viajes que
decidí desconectarme de todo me propuse
salir de la rutina y más porque el
primer viaje que hacíamos como amigas
con el propósito de celebrar a la
primera amiga que se casaba
bueno la expectativa era alta las
emociones estaban a flor de piel
recuerdo que nos hospedamos en un depa
increíble que hicimos actividades
completamente diferentes y bueno las
pláticas eran interminables el chisme
tras chisme tras chisme
pero como peco un poquito de romántica
el último día en la alberca con un cielo
estrellado y el reflejo de la luna fue
el cierre de nuestro viaje donde
lloramos nos dijimos lo importante que
éramos la una para la otra
recordamos nuestros tiempos de
preparatoria
y me dije a mí misma esto es lo que
quiero transmitirle a las personas que
recuerdan estos lazos de una amistad
verdadera que a pesar de los años la
distancia el tiempo y los sueños de cada
una
seguimos siendo las mismas mejores
amigas
y es aquí donde descubrí dónde era mi
lugar emprendí mi negocio
donde diseño experiencias de viajes
únicas para que las personas conecten
con sus seres queridos y celebren la
amistad
créanme no hay momento perfecto a mi me
pasaron mil cosas por la cabeza
carla tienes que tener un ahorro
carla empieza mientras trabajas
carla
y si no vendes de que vas a vivir
pues yo hice todo al revés
no tenía ahorros tenía deudas y dejé mi
trabajo
y saben algo
saben que si tenía el apoyo de los que
me quieren eso me basto junto con una
combinación de miedo y unas ganas de ser
ese espíritu libre que hoy por hoy lo
considero la mejor decisión que he
tomado en mi vida
entendí que emprender era decirle sí a
mis sueños aprendí que no importa si soy
la empresa más grande y exitosa o la más
pequeña si lo intenté y no lo logré si
probé esa idea loca y funcionó perfecto
si voy a salir en televisión
si voy a llegar a los millones de
seguidores y voy a romperla en redes
sociales o me voy a quedar con mis mil
seguidores créanme no importa nada de
eso este sentimiento de hacer lo que me
apasiona y me hace sentir viva
no tiene precio que valga y sí sí es
equilibrio pero algo que me prometí a mí
misma fue nunca descuidar me ni
descuidar mi vida personal
y hoy por hoy compruebo lo que un día me
dijo mi papá y aprendiera a disfrutar la
vida a mi manera
descubrí que la amistad más verdadera
nace de esas experiencias que nos hace a
cada uno únicos conecte la adrenalina de
cruzar un puente antes de que pasaron
tren mis ganas de ser un espíritu libre
desde pequeña el amor y el apoyo
incondicional de mis padres mis
herramientas profesionales de mi vida
godín
y mi cariño por mis amigas
si hoy quisiera que se quedaran con una
idea sería esta que el emprendimiento de
tus sueños se trate de conectar tus
vivencias y atarlas a eso que te hace
vibrar y sentirte libre muchas gracias
[Aplausos]